what's the meaning of life why are we
here we talked about the rise of human
civilization it seems like we're
engineers at heart we build cool stuff
uh better and better use of energy
channeling energy to be productive
why
what's it all for
you're getting metaphysical on me very
there's a beautiful boat to the left of
us like why do we do that this this boat
that sailed the ocean
then we build models of it to celebrate
great engineering of the past
to engineer is divine
you can make lots of arguments as while
we're here we're here we're they're here
to entertain ourselves or we're here to
to create something
that's beautiful or something that's
functional
i think if you're an engineer you
entertain yourself by creating something
that's both beautiful and functional
so i think all three of those things
it's entertaining but
it's ethical
you know you got to admire
you know the the first person that built
a bridge
crossing a chasm or
the first person to work out the problem
of how to get running water to a village
uh the first person to figure out how to
you know
dam up a river
or mastered agriculture or
the guy that figured out you know how to
grow fruit on trees or crated orchards
you know and maybe one day he had like
10 fruit trees he's pretty proud of
himself
so that's functional
there is also something to that just
like you said that's just
beautiful it does get you closer to
um
like you said the divine something
when you when you step back and look at
the entirety of it
a collective of humans
using
a beautiful invention or creation or
just
just something about this
instrument is creating
a beautiful piece of music
that seems just right that's what we're
here for whatever the divine is it seems
like we're here for that that and i of
course love talking to you because uh
from the engineering perspective the
functional is ultimately the mechanism
towards the beauty
isn't there something beautiful about
about making the world a better place
for people that you love
your friends your family
or yourself
yeah
you know
when you think about the the entire arc
of
human existence
and you roll the clock back 500 000
years and you think about every struggle
of everyone that came before us and
everything they had to overcome in order
to put you here right now
you know
you kind of
you got to admire that right you got to
respect that
that's a heck of a gift they gave us
it's also
a heck of a
responsibility don't screw it up
if i dropped you 500 000 years ago i
said figure out steel refining
or or you know
fake
figure out rate silicon chips fab
reproduction or or whatever it is why or
fire
and so now we're here and i guess the
way you repay them is you fix everything
in front of your face you can
right and that means
to someone like elon it means get us off
the planet
right
to someone like me it's like i think
you know fix the energy in in the system
and that gives me hope michael this is
an incredible conversation you're an
incredible human it's a huge honor you
would sit down with me
thank you so much for talking today
yeah thanks for having me alex
you